good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is Ingram angle from Washington
tonight the flimflam gang that's the
focus of tonight's
angle all right the talking point dour
for globalists is that conservatives
skeptical about the mcconell Schumer
border deal don't really want to solve
the crisis they're just bowing down to
Donald Trump who opposes it it's not
surprising I guess but it it's
it's I mean it's deeply cynical people
are people's you know there a lot of
people's lives are are hanging the
balance here I think it's a fundamental
problem with trumpism right trumpism is
about nihilism it's the burn it down
caucus right they don't want to
legislate because legislation is solving
problems right they don't want the
government to
work similar flimsy thinking coming from
that conservative stalwart Mitt Romney
and other Trump loathing pro-amnesty
Republicans like Tom Tillis it is
immoral for me to think you look the
other way because you think this is the
Lynch pin for president Trump to win I
do not want to be a part of of history
that fails uh fails
democracy Senator this actually is
democracy what's not respecting
democracy is What's Happening Now hiding
bills hundreds of pages long until the
last possible minute then forcing a vote
before anyone's had the chance to really
dissect it so I find that kind of
offensive given that they're still
sitting on the text we ask why can't we
see it and they say well it's in a lot
of different places it's not all in one
document that's fine uh most of us on
this stage are accustomed to uh looking
at a whole bunch of different pieces of
documents we can do that no still won't
let us have it oh okay it must be really
bad now shills for the cheap labor Lobby
or a dime a dozen on Capitol Hill we've
talked about this for years and they
think you're were stupid and that they
could sneak through a massive foreign
worker expansion that still allows Biden
to wave in close to 2 million migrants
in one year now that's a win-win isn't
it for both Biden and McConnell you get
the Ukraine money you get more migrants
and you get political cover for the
Democrats but it is a gut punch to
American workers no wonder they don't
want Senators Consulting with Trump
instead they want senators listen to
that stalwart conservative Liz
Cheney if it's true that McConnell said
you know basically you know we thought
we had a deal but now it looks like you
know Trump's going to be the nominee and
he wants to run on this um I mean that
that is so cynical and and
irresponsible now let me be clear if
there was any group of people who have a
right to be cynical it's the American
who would like to see enforcement of our
border laws now a lot of you have been
watching me on television or listening
to my radio show or podcast over the
years you know that this has been an
issue that I personally have focused on
for 17 years and Time After Time
politicians promised us that they are
actually willing to enforce the Border I
mean really enforce the Border but then
when you read the deals it's really
amnesty plus a gargantuan foreign worker
increase with a promise of some type of
enforcement or some limitation it's
always a morphus never enforceable and
now I promise we're going to enter a new
stage of this dark comedy and we'll get
to more of this in a moment the same
players are going to pretend that all
this time they're negotiating a new
border deal a new new border deal and
they're going to claim that they've
tweaked the language and then the media
will pretend that the changes mean that
the Border problem is so solved oh and
of course it's all going to take a few
months for these new policies to be
fully effective and you're going to have
to hire new agents and you're going to
have to make sure everything is properly
implemented and there there may be some
court cases but don't worry the problem
is
solved and then when it's 2025 and
heaven forbid if Biden has been
reelected and the immigrants are still
pouring in with even greater numbers the
Democrats and their lackes in the GOP
establishment will laugh all the way to
the bank so yeah we have every right to
be cynical look at what's happened in
the country in the last three years but
we actually aren't the true cynics here
the true cynics are those who put the
short-term interests of their donors
over the long-term interests of the
American people the true cynics are
those who go on television and lie about
the enforcement plans it's going to work
this time when they know very well none
of the those plans will be implemented
by this crowd we're not cynical we're
actually pragmatic and we're energized
and we are going to do everything we can
to prevent you from further damaging
America and you know who you are and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else